Net Cat gives us a simple model
of a program using the network.
But it's a lot simpler than the way
that a standard web browser and
server use the network.
Browsers and servers don't just
handle a single request or
a few requests one after the other.
They also work on several
requests at the same time.
When your browser loads
a web page from a server.
It usually has to load
a lot of different files.
The HTML itself, plus images,
scripts, CSS, and other data.
The more that it can do this
in parallel the faster it can
render that page onto your screen.
Or imagine that you're in charge of
the server that's sending this video
to your browser.
You're probably not the only
person watching it right now.
You might be near the end of
the video while someone else is just
starting to watch it.
So the data that the server is sending
to you isn't in sync with what it's
sending to that other person's browser.
And there are a lot of different ways
that programs can handle multiple
connections at once.
One of the most basic ones is
what early web servers did.
And what many programs
such as SSHD still do.
Whenever a new connection comes in,
the server process forks,
it asks the operating system to split
it in two, like a cell dividing.
A different model that many more recent
servers use is to create a pool of
processes or threads, each of which
can handle one connection at a time.
And this is faster than
starting new processes.
But it does have the downside that
there's a limit to how many requests may
be handled at once before
things start to slow down.
And finally a third model is
to have a single process that
quickly switches between handling
requests as they become available.
There are a few different facilities and
operating systems for
doing this efficiently,
such as the epole function in Linux.
But before your server
can handle a request,
the client has to know how to
get in touch with your server.
Up ahead, we'll take a look at DMS,
the directory system for internet hosts.